prisons because I was interested in what
was happening inside of them but I
didn't want to go in as a photographer
or in quotes a tourist looking around
and I happen to find out about an
opportunity through the prison
University project which is a nonprofit
organization in San Francisco that
offers an AAA program to the men inside
San Quentin so I started going in as a
volunteer professor teaching the
first-ever history of photography class
there and although the class was about
history and about learning the
importance of the image I wanted the men
in the class to also get a feel for what
it was like to create and to insert
their own creativity into an image so
one of the exercises we came up with was
this idea of mapping a photograph of
looking at it dissecting what's there
and figuring out how to insert your own
narrative into the piece and one of the
things that I really love about
photography is that it's this generous
medium that allows all of us to become
part of what we're looking at it also
rewards looking at detail and I feel
like we can understand complex
situations we can understand other
people if we understand the details of
their life and what they're interested
in and for me photography really stands
in is something that can do that quicker
okay so this is one of the images we
used this is a photograph by eggleston
and what I did was to print the image on
two sides of one paper 11 by 17 inches
and give different photographs to the
men in the class and they were allowed
to take the images back to their housing
unit live with it for a couple of weeks
Mac one side of it and then use their
mappings to create a narrative about
what they saw in the photograph I told
the the guys who the artists were but
really nothing about the photograph of
the idea was really for them to
investigate it themselves so this is an
example of the mapping and I like the
details that he notes the thing that
really stands out for me with Marvin's
dissection is the
where he circles the door and writes an
arrow that says figure this out as if he
himself is trying to figure a way to get
out of the photograph or maybe by
extension how to get out of prison I
talked about how I think photography is
a generous medium that allows us to
insert ourselves into the image and the
narrative that Marvin wrote about this
photograph was based on his insistence
that no matter what I said this
photograph was taken in South Central LA
while he grew up and he creates on the
bottom you can see this complicated kind
of family tree about all the people he
knew in South Central and what would
happen kind of during their their daily
excursions so again he takes a
photograph that has nothing to do with
his particular existence and finds it a
way to make it about something that he
can understand another example of that
is a photograph by Steven Shore
this was done by John and I love I
really do love all the details that he
figures out here he didn't know the date
of the photograph but because he spent
so much time looking at it he discovered
the marquee of the movie theater and the
movie what's it called Night Moves is
playing and he remembers that that came
out in 1975 and through that he's able
to date the photograph he also talks
about a sign that you can see on the
right of the photograph that says
discounts and he sees how that's a newer
sign and from that he realizes that this
is a neighborhood that used to be
wealthy that has now fallen on hard
times and the narrative that he creates
based on this photograph is one about a
man the character in the center who's
leaving prison and going back to a home
that he just doesn't recognize anymore
one of the things that's interesting in
prison is that there are no computers so
most people are writing by hand and
that's something I just don't see
anymore so I also like looking to set
the beauty of the handwriting and the
way that it's interacting with the paper
this is a photograph that I'm sure many
of you know by Joel Sternfeld and if you
don't know the story behind it it looks
like there's you know an intentional
fire and the firefighter is just
ignoring the picture but if you know
more about the picture you know that
it's a controlled burn and it brings up
something that Debbie mentioned this
morning during her talk and something I
think about a lot with photography or
with any creative endeavor and that is
that you can start with fact or fiction
but inevitably one recalls the other and
if that's not used in a political
circumstance I actually I do find it
disturbing when it's used in the
political world but when it's used in
the art world I think it's really
fascinating because it talks about how
we're always struggling to come to terms
with our existence which is fact and
fiction mingle together so I just point
that out because this photograph is
really about fact in fiction so Joseph
who's looking at this picture obviously
notes the fire and his narrative is
written from the perspective of somebody
who owns the farm and I'm glad to hear
you laugh and I'm going to talk about
that in a minute so but first he writes
about the perspective of loss and how
his childhood place is going to be going
away but what will never go away is this
recipe for a special pie mrs. McLean's
pie and when I tell people that I work
in prison people kind of expect that
everything I'm going to have to say
about it is dour and upsetting and
depressing and indeed there is plenty of
that inside of prison but there's also a
lot of humor and lightheartedness and
love and that kind of thing comes across
in that really kind of sweet recipe for
pie while I was teaching I did that for
three semesters I was given access to an
amazing archive of photographic
negatives taken at San Quentin State
Prison between 1938 in about 1984 they
were all taken by correctional officers
as a way to document in that events
inside the prison there's tens of
thousands of negatives and they were
just kind of moldering away in a storage
facility nobody was seemingly taking
care of them and I was really fortunate
to be given access to them so since
about 2012 I've been going through them
organizing them scanning them and trying
to make sense of them it's interesting
to me that the correctional officers
were using four by five cameras up until
the 80s I mean that does tell you that
change happens very slowly
inside of a prison but because of that
the negatives are gorgeous
and they make beautiful prints although
as I said they document everything
inside the prison for murders two
suicides you know two really very
painful things to look at two weddings
and parties and people that jobs kind of
all the things that happen outside
happen inside with the added element of
violence so the negatives that were not
organized some of them are in these
envelopes and there's a date and a brief
description but a lot of them are open
to interpretation so the first part of
just working this with this was just
trying to make kind of categories of
what I would find
and there were images that clearly
reference life in prison like this
escape dummy that somebody had made one
of the kind of on a side note one of the
things you learn when you spend a lot of
time in prison is that there's
incredible creativity inside because
there are a lack of resources people
have to figure out in many ways how to
take care of themselves so although I
don't know how this escape dummy was
made somehow it was molded with found
material and then obviously using real
hair to create the eyebrows and the hair
this is an image of a suicide
this place in San Quentin is called
suicide alley I'm sorry the next image
is this pretty gruesome just to give you
a heads up
there's images of traumas large and
small and you really have to wonder you
know why would someone even take a
photograph of a single band-aid and then
there's also really beautiful images
that don't reference prison at all you'd
have no idea you were there so this is
from a family visit this is called
Mother's Day you can probably guess from
the clothes it's the 70s 1976 yes
this one's called two inmates and a seal
so sometimes the title Ain is ink is
incredibly obvious but I also kind of I
find kind of funny so as I said I was
going through the negatives trying to
organize them and on their own I think
they're incredibly interesting to look
at but I also felt like there was a key
component missing and that was figuring
out how to collaborate with the men
inside to bring this archive to life in
a different way as I mean I just look I
call myself an outsider I've been
working in the prison since 2011 but
I've never been incarcerated so when I
look at them I bring my experience as a
free person to what I see there but when
the men inside look at them they're able
to interpret them and escort us around
the image and show us things that we may
or may have not seen things that we miss
and ways that we can then see the
photograph and in a new light so I used
the same principle that I did with the
photographs by well-known men which was
- excuse me well-known photographers
which was to invite men to become part
of a photography group where I brought
images in from the archive we sat and
talked about them and then they were
able to bring images back to their
housing unit to map and to write about
so this is a picture of Kevin who is
part of the project this is in the
housing unit North blog and I want to
show you just a couple it
samples of those so here's an image
without any writing without any
intervention on it I'm called stabbing
in the gym and then here's the
interpretation done by Ruben Ramirez who
was one of my students and also worked
on this project and I just I love how he
writes about the picture and after
reading his words I can never look at
this image in the same way it's no
longer this cold clinical image of
someone who's been stabbed it's an image
about striving it's an image about
dualities and it's an image about
experience and he writes across the body
which i think is also really beautiful
the arms symbolized buttresses
attempting to prevent the Fallen
attempting to prevent the structural
failure of a once-proud Cathedral
encouragement and enlightenment versus
indifference and authoritative tyranny
and says I have someone look at an image
of brutality and to be able to see it in
these architectural terms was really
stunning to me I mean it's it's poetic
its alluring but it doesn't deny the
brutality either of the image and then
the Ruben is someone who didn't have a
lot of education before he came to
prison he ended up getting his a a
degree in college in the college program
but he was so profoundly moved by the
image and found this personal and kind
of enlightening way to talk about
something I'm I'm interested obviously
in issues of prison reform and how we
can change prisons and I don't believe
that people are interested in that
through numbers and statistics I think
we make change through stories and
through personal communication and
that's really you know what this project
is about here's another example of a
photograph that was written on this was
at a family visit and it's kind of an
amusing image because there's this man
in the front luxuriating and this
woman's laughs and he can't see that
behind him is another man with his hands
on this woman's shoulders and so you
don't know exactly what's happening here
and it's shahu mapped this
very very smartly at the bottom just
said this is a picture of free love
which makes a lot of sense and then the
final example was an image that was
mapped by Shakur and what appears to be
a fight being photographed is again this
commingling effect in fiction because as
you look at it you notice that there's a
man in the bottom corner looking up at
the photographer and obviously if there
was a fight going on this couldn't be
happening
so what Shakur figured out was that this
was a reenactment
that correctional officers were
photographing as evidence of what and
what an altercation could look like so
working on all of these photographic
projects and thinking about stories
encouraged me to work on a very
different kind of storytelling project
inside the prison which is the podcast
ear hustle which I started with Ellen
woods and Antoine Williams both pictured
here who at the time were incarcerated
at San Quentin and our idea was to tell
the everyday stories of life inside
prison told from the perspective of
those who live it originally the idea
was to air it only inside prisons but
while we were working on it we entered a
contest through radio topia and were
lucky enough to win this contest and the
podcast ended up being aired outside the
prison and we're now in our starting our
fifth season when we started the podcast
I knew nothing about audio neither did
Earl on or Antoine or the other men we
worked with so we really had to learn
everything together as a group and I
think that's a really wonderful way to
start a collaboration when everyone
starts at the same place so I want to
play a small clip from the podcast this
is from an episode called looking out
which is about this guy Roach who loves
animals and takes care of all kinds of
critters inside prison and so that for
me that the topic of the podcast this
episode is really about finding love and
giving love inside a place where it's
really hard to do that and for me the
podcast is very similar to the way I
look at photography which is it's about
details
it's about observation and it's
about the quiet small things this this
clip also really highlights the way the
podcast works
Orlin and i are the hosts that bring you
in and out of the story
there's varied emotions within the
podcast and it has a rich sound design
which is all done by antoine williams
okay
so here's that clip to me I think roads
look like the original Jesus Christ you
know a baby got the dreadlocks he's like
he's from the earth and if he could just
be wearing a leaf and he got this one
little thing that he do he just door
sniffing on his dreadlocks I know I've
seen him do that he grabs his hair and
he pulls it in front of his nose and
just sniffs hey you just be looking at
me fYI I do smell my dreads I put
different oil on each one of them they
smell good they smell like I just came
out the dirt hanging out with roots and
stuff but you know what though when
people from the outside look at ropes
they be like I'll do weird man I ain't
talking to do but Roach is a cool dude
my name is Ronald Reaper but I go by
Roach my relationship with people is
pretty strained I don't trust them early
on they have been a source of pain for
me so Roach is about 40 years old and
he's a pretty shy guy until you know
when I was a child before I was removed
from the care of my mom's custody she
tried to drown me a couple times in the
tub
and then she stopped and she left the
bathroom she was crying I knew she was
unhappy or sad that something I did I
wanted to actually comfort her but I
didn't know how to do it I don't
remember her face and I haven't seen her
since so again that's a really good
example of what the podcast sound like
going from things that will make you
laugh to things that are arresting and
in quite upsetting uhm I've heard this
clip so many times and every time I hear
the end where he says I don't remember
my mother's face
it's such an intense thing to say it's
not saying I don't remember her but I
don't remember her face and that's such
a profound loss and I'm gonna end on a
on a little bit of a happier note though
people ask me a lot how do you define
success and how do you know when a
project works and for me a project is
successful when it inspires other people
to do their own work and do their own
storytelling and this is a picture of
Ruben Ramirez who did this incredible
piece and I think he's watching the live
feed so hi Ruben he's very shy though so
anyway um after we worked on the project
together and through talking through
Fatah about photography he told me that
he could now see fascination everywhere
and isn't that a great way to think
about life that we can see fashion
fascination everywhere no matter where
we are the other the other thing I love
is that when work you do inspires other
people to not just think but to get
creative themselves and it doesn't
matter what the medium is it's the idea
that it's created the impulse to make
and to share and so I just wanted to
share these three amazing things that
your hustle listeners have done so
whether it's creating a blanket through
knitting or a digital drawing or
incredible nail art it all represents
the impulse that we have which is to be
creative and to tell stories and
hopefully connect in the world that can
feel very distant and cold so I'm gonna
leave it there and hope that you all
feel the spirit to create
[Applause]
all right thank you
that was fabulous and I do go Ruben is
watching Hey I'm Vince how are you guys
yeah
we're thrilled to have Raja hot Ally
with us today when we try to match
people for these conversations we look
for many different things
pairing differing personalities or
shared interests or colleagues sometimes
we look for young and dynamic social
entrepreneurs or even an author or even
a playwright in some cases occasionally
we'll look for a television host or
presenter or the commentator from place
like CNN or even an op-ed writer from a
newspaper like the New York Times or Ted
speaker maybe a lawyer but never one
person who has done all of those things
and continues to do many of them he's
able to keep his sense of humor a few
days ago he rang in the New Year with a
series of tweets charting the last 10
years beginning of the decade I was
completely broke my credit was shot I
was driving a 97 Camry without a door
handle my health was terrible I was
single I'll close out the decade with an
amazing wife three lovely kids
a Honda minivan better credit and a
career keep hustling was a hot Ally
[Applause]
welcome to our little chobe mela for
those who don't know chobe mela is the
first festival of photography in asia
and it was created by shakadou l'olam a
singular force who has dedicated his
life to the pursuit of truth
photographer author curator and activist
but not always in that order
he gave a voice to those who could see
but were not being heard arming them
with the language of photography and
empowering a generation of photographers
to turn the camera on themselves and
their culture for the world to see there
are those in this room who know you
personally those who know about you and
your journey and those who know of you
and all of us are happy to see you here
today because while you may not have
been in this room your presence and
influence has been helped felt here for
many years
please welcome Shaheed Allah Lum and
wash a hot Holi
Thank You Vince if I wasn't married I
could score two dates off that intro
that was amazing
how's everyone doing thank you for that
overwhelmingly enthusiastic response
that was that was awesome lovely thank
you to my people the proletariat
watching from the cafeteria and the
spillover thank you to all those who are
watching us on the youtubes and thank
you to shahida alum who has come here
all the way from Dhaka Bangladesh to be
with us today for the storyteller summon
thank you today so sure he that I met
three years ago in Dhaka when I was
actually working with Facebook Google in
the UN to help some young manga they
should change agents and artists and I
just reached out to you through our
mutual friend Salma to be a judge to
help mentor these kids and you came by
we met and this was before you were
public enemy number one a lot could
happen in three years right and and I
never would have thought that he would
be in Washington DC in the nation's
capital three years later you have a
very eventful life my friend and as we
talk about it and I think it's very
important Time magazine Person of the
Year celebrated photographer many people
who were watching they're like oh hey
doll I'm so inspiring I wish I could be
like that Who am I I'm just an average
Jose or Joe and I think the origin story
of you superheroes is very important and
if I may I want to begin with you know
we've talked before and I always always
called you the accidental photographer
and this journey began with an
accidental birth can you explain that
okay well it was a candid moment the
picture is of my parents and my brother
and my sister my dad's microbiologist my
mum's schoolteacher
two kids nice happy family my dad's
elder sister passes away leaving four
orphans and a family with two kids
becomes a family of six kids my mum does
extra work my dad does too and they make
make ends meet but they certainly don't
plan on a seventh child at that time
yeah but well it happens so it was much
later I think about 29 or something like
that my mother Candide he tells me you
were an accident well did it sting at 29
I really like Tampa we have a very well
she's passed away we had a lovely
relationship and it was nice the way she
said it as well but but speaking about
your mom before me you know your mother
is this force full foot too and a
dynamite and and and and you know we're
going to talk about this not only as you
as a photographer as an artist as an
activist but education runs deep and
it's almost like a genetic inheritance
for you can you explain that yeah well
my mother she's in Kolkata my dad wants
a beauty and educated why smart madam
completely but you know he's
microbiologist in the army very eligible
bachelor lots of people want you know
lots of applicants but then he wants he
wants an educated wife and my
grandmother gives in she's not really
interested in the bride going to
university so my mother puts on a burka
my dad's younger brother takes her to
visit her friends and that's how she
graduates after partition comes over to
Bangladesh my mother wants to set up
school no one's interested so she
pitches his tent she buys a tent for ten
taka
pitches his tent in the middle of a
playground 14 kids it's now possibly the
best-known school and college for girls
in the country
I I just wanna I just want to repeat
that that one woman a four foot
something dynamo takes a just pitches a
tent and fast forward five decades later
and you just said as one of the best
well-known schools in Bangladesh
continue please and of course in the
school she does more than teach
arithmetic in Matt's music theater I was
involved that's my mother teaching me to
play the harmonium so all of that is
part and parcel of what this is but not
everything was easy but I'll come to
that later
three women very important in my life my
sister on the Left Rena my my partner in
the middle my mum on the right powerful
personalities and didn't always go too
well but I'll pass on that for now but
but important how they shaped you I mean
ompletely your users throughout life I
continue to be I mean they're very
important women but other women too but
other very important women its idea who
ranima for instance while I was in jail
she went every day to jail mm-hmm
no one could convince basically she said
I don't trust these guys I want to be
here I want to make sure you're there
she made that trip every day but the
others idea my niece Salma here Julie in
Sri Lanka and I'm Tara and Nepal I mean
they've all played a huge role but I'll
move actually to 1971 which for me was
very significant this is a picture by
penny Tweedy and she actually gave us
that print when we first did chubby mama
as was mentioned and this is a woman
going through a field with a rifle I
don't know who she is disappeared
perhaps in the history books this is not
a person who will feature but the war of
liberation was our battle all all of us
we wanted liberation and for me what was
very significant comes to
this image this was taken on the 14th of
December 1971 the killing fields of
robbers are taken by a received a load
there who actually won the Pioneer Award
at National Geographic before it was
discontinued but for me what was very
significant was how through that war I
changed and what happened immediately
this was something up is being done by
Pakistani armies when they knew they
were going to leave the country they
were losing they wanted to [ __ ] the
country intellectually you know so the
leading artists scholars journalists
were all invited and this is what we
found in the 17th December we got
independent on the 16th I said the
nation was crippled and you know my
parents wanted me to carry on studying
my sister was in in Liverpool so they
managed to cobble up a ticket to one-way
ticket but but you know if we make for
those of you don't know what the 1971
war I mean it was you know Bangladesh
was called East Pakistan and for those
of you don't know geography Americans
are really bad at geography
there's Pakistan this small country
called India and then Bangladesh and so
Bangladesh from the inception of 1947
one in its own independence and this
1971 war it was one of the worst rapes
of the 20th century it was Pakistani
Muslims taking vengeance against
Bangladeshi Muslims and in Pakistan to
this day you don't mention this it's
it's it's it doesn't happen or if it was
it was it was their fault
and there is this lingering trauma and
and I am I appreciate you mentioned that
that they went after the intellectuals
because they always go after the artists
and intellectuals and thinkers those are
that those voices are always the most
threatening it seems to power so no no
it's important here I suspect Native
Americans get left out in Britain
Colonials and get less left out so there
are those accidental emissions yeah but
so I'm in Britain
and I'm from a middle-class home so
you're meant to become a doctor or an
engineer that's it the soybean doctor
engineer business failure lawyers okay
yeah anyway so I I studied biochemistry
and genetics I graduate I then go on to
a PhD goodbye yet so far in the box and
that's the stage when I get introduced
to the Socialist Workers Party let
politics get very involved in race
issues class issues all of that sort of
thing polish Poland solid an arc
movement and that's when I discover the
power of photography Oh exactly
and I think does Bangladesh needs yet
another research chemist and your mother
would say yes precisely
yes yes so anyway they don't know about
this I'm doing this piece for tea but
while I'm doing this son he lit a few
pictures and I decide to test it out to
see if I can actually make a living out
of it and there's an advert in the
newspaper for photographer in a small
studio called The Young Rascals and
basically you take pictures of kids so
I'd go around spread of skin rug a blue
background and take happy pictures of
kids it paid well five hundred dollars a
week in those days lots of money what I
also did was amateur photography and
things like that and then I'm doing nude
studies on myself because I'm the only
one available no but I was that was
interesting it's all DIY right you had
no training
you got you got possession of this
camera and you're like this is
interesting let me just go out and see
what I can do and actually getting the
camera was also a bit of an interesting
accident because you know this was
Freddie Laker days some of you will
remember the Laker Airways cheap 90
pounds you could get a London to New
York flight south oh poor student this
is my chance to go to the United States
so again on I get on a Sky train a
friend of mine tells me cameras achieved
dollars low buy me a camera from the
United States I go to
I'm not sure B and H was there but
Heston Jewish shop you know I buy a NIC
on FM must tripod and rickety tripod a
flash gun and everything and I go around
hitch those were the days you could
hitch hitching around the United States
you know Canada come back to London he
doesn't have the money to pay for it I'm
stuck with a camera so I take some
pictures and you know this next one is
from that period and riched richard
moses will be jealous this is infrared
photography it's a beautiful photo thank
you but you know that's what I was doing
trying to take pretty pictures but this
really wasn't why I had come into
photography one very interesting thing
happened at that time because I was
taking these pictures of kids but I
wasn't happy about the photography I was
doing yeah so I complained I said what
are you talking about you're a star
photography make more money than
everyone else five hundred dollars a
week
yeah it's rushing it yeah I started
thinking you know if I stay in this
setup and everyone tells me I'm a great
photographer I start believing this you
know you know I'm in the zone of comfort
and everyone tells me nice things and
too dangerous so that was when I decided
to make a clean break go over to
Bangladesh I'm gonna become a
photojournalist but of course I've got
no crack record I've never worked for a
newspaper I don't have a portfolio this
is what I want to do but you know there
was money to be made and that this my
friend is truth to power yeah this is
the war on Christmas I waved by Muslims
yeah I took rats I took pretty women I
took flowers whatever came yeah well
exactly but something else was
interesting I decided to go back home
and live with my parents they're very
important people in my life I'd left
home when I was 17 I came back as a 29
year old I wanted to know these people
and I knew it wasn't going to be easy I
lived independently for all these years
go home in my parents house middle-class
home their home this home help and this
little boy meson he cleans what we call
the drawing-room where we watch
television you know
except that he's he's not allowed to sit
inside to watch TV with us he sits
outside that doorway and what we'd done
by then we meet set up an agency I'll
come back to that later but we were
using calendars and calendars at that
time where they have pretty pictures you
know we don't have naked women by 4
waterfalls but we have you know mosques
and nature and pretty women things like
that we decided to use our calendar for
social messages so this picture of me as
I'm watching television was printed in
our calendar I gave a copy to my son I
gave a copy to my mother
the following day my son sat inside that
room to watch TV with us yeah very well
it's and I think for for people just if
you've ever gone to South Asia the the
class divide is so immense that this is
a revolutionary photo to have someone
literally invade and enter that space it
shows you that all politics are personal
and how you can actually change a
mindset of your family with one single
photograph and this was my own family
very immense rated people but so what
I'm also doing again I no one's hiring
me to do photo journalism but there's a
general I've left an independent nation
I've come back to find a general has
taken over so I'm in the streets taking
pictures of the resistance and this
treaty Azad was one of this was other
Shaheed Minar later on this young man
was very important on his back it says
LED democracy be freed and on the 10th
of November 1987 he was killed by the
police
this is at a campus in fact the
University where my partner is to teach
where she set up the first department of
anthropology but so I'm taking these
pictures but over a period of time I'm
88 we have a massive flood that's when I
get commissioned you know that's when
people suddenly find an interest Hama
yes be exactly the poverty porn for the
West this struggle for democracy no one
was in corners yeah but come to come the
floods I get Commission
it's not bad either but while that's
going on there is this wedding the
wedding of the daughter of a powerful
Minister taking place at a time when the
nation is reeling under this devastating
flood everyone's there you know the
who's who have Bangladesh is there but
no one mentions a word The ministers the
owner of a very very powerful newspaper
everyone knows the rules interestingly I
tried to show this work it was going to
be shown on the 10th of November 89
exactly two years to Noura Saints death
alia small says the sponsor backs off by
15 year of French Revolution 1989 but
that doesn't seem to matter so I I don't
have a sponsor I don't have a space we
put the show up anyway if you know mind
can you go back to the previous photo
and then now just go back to the wedding
so I just want you to reflect us on this
because in Pakistan in India in
Bangladesh this is common if you were to
tell people this to go yeah this happens
all the time why do you think the
juxtaposition of these two photos which
are so common and well-known to everyone
among a bish Pakistan South in India is
so dangerous to people well everyone
knows but no one speaks and I think
that's that's where the difference is
and while those connections are what we
make we don't specify them as such and
here was I challenging a military
general challenging his Minister and
talking about the reality at a time when
the nation was reeling under those
floods but something else happened these
pictures the flood pictures anyway again
the West is interested in floods and
disasters are all shot so this exhibit
went to the side gallery in in Newcastle
and then to a show in Belfast and I'm
staying with Irish Prince paddy and
Deborah they have a lovely line and five
year old daughter Karina and I'm back
from the show I'm putting some coins in
the pocket
and she's standing at the doorway
staring at me I say what's the matter
Karina
she is you've got money yes I've got
money but but you're from Bangladesh hmm
five year old girl
five year old girl and I it got me
thinking about the sort of social
political cultural environment within
which a child grows where she's
incapable of seeing in Bangladeshi
has anything other than an icon of
poverty because these are the pictures
she's grown up with and that has been
our you know our identity so that's when
I decided I've set up an agency so we
could tell our own stories and it's so
powerful right like when people hear us
say that because all you're always
whining and complaining but and I'm
looking at that frame to your left what
gets in the frame what gets left out and
what gets left out is the the narratives
of 150 million people in Bangladesh to
the point where a five year old girl
once you think someone that she just
thinks this this is unimaginable well
there is the other side as well we did
manage to get the general down and
suddenly this the same gallery that had
turned our show down because actually
they said it's photography it's not art
so we can't show it but the same art
gallery once the general goes accepts to
show photography and in four and a half
days in three and a half days we had
400,000 people coming to see Wow
it was incredible we had near riots at
their entrance and people would just be
shoveled in it's you know we had no
money
this cardboard right yes exactly yeah we
just a cardboard in behave that's it
but you know for us it was still very
powerful that photographs could have
that engagement and that people were so
hungry for those images how is the
response like if you have 400,000 people
literally coming just to see photos on
cardboard how how did how did the people
respond to the art they were blown away
because you see another very interesting
thing happened at that time the military
general had censored and initially the
newspapers crowded redacting spaces and
then they decided they wouldn't publish
so that was very brave they
the military general they decided they
wouldn't publish so the people were
hungry they wanted to see them think we
finally got the general down so there
was huge response but what it also led
to was an election and for me this image
was very important because I felt that
she with her vote was avenging new
Hussein's death but then you know
elections we tend to think elections are
all there is to democracy hope change
and I soon discovered otherwise the
campaign this is colored as here who
later became prime minister on a
campaign trail it's joyous exuberant
this is colored this year after she gets
elected and you know the relationship
between her and the public sort of
changes but of course it's true for all
of them again we taken all these
pictures no one was interested 29th of
April 1991 a cyclone suddenly everyone's
interested in pictures again and the New
York Times contacts us be one those
pictures they sent a sample pictures we
have them but and you know we've just
started a small agency in New York Times
big client we don't really want to lose
this but film you know you got a stayed
so we write to them to say we got those
pictures but we don't think that's the
story so Nancy Lee the deputy picture
editor to be fair to her says ok tell us
what the story is and we did a full-page
spread on the New York Times about
farmers replanting seeds fishermen going
up fixing their boats people helping out
each other and to the best of my
knowledge possibly the only photo spread
at that time that didn't dwell on bodies
so that was important but we felt yes it
can be done but we also thought of other
things you know while I I was
questioning what white breasts and
photographers got me in doing but I as a
male middle class photographer was also
someone in power
you know if I'm photographing a woman
who doesn't have a daughter shot on my
face the control is with me and she very
rarely gets to decide what image it'll
be so we decide
we would challenge our own position and
so this is a group of ten year old
working-class kids we started teaching
photography zero and both girls are
significant the girl on the left is drew
bear the girl on the right is Molly who
later became my assistant and now he's
an editor in one of the leading
newspapers so the first day I'm working
with them we did this we also started
training women photographers the first
day we're doing this I show pictures to
Molly well and other kids and Molly
looks at this picture this this is a
picture taken by one of my students as
his earring PU who's passed away sadly
and she says oh that's the fire in
number 10 what happened in number 10
what's it is he the owner took the
bodies in Dublin and Raynard night hmm
how do you know everyone knows what
happened nothing ever happens she says
and then reads says if I had a camera
I'd take his picture I'd put that guy in
jail hmm no you know I am a
photojournalist you know we know our
pictures often don't make a difference
but the fact that this 10 year old girl
had that belief was something that that
fired me up and again if you don't mind
me asking when you when she was given a
camera or when she was given your
mentorship but when she I'm assuming had
someone like you just believe in her
what was the change if any no whoa look
firstly we just had fun we stick around
and I remember the first day I said
where do you want to go so they gave a
whole list of they'd go to Cox's Bazaar
they'd go to Sunderbans at photograph a
tiger they'd go to this was a huge list
of what they were going to do that day
directly there and I had a little
station wagon and yeah they were 11 kids
they were meant to be 10 and they took
another one on so they were 11 we'd all
get into this every five minutes I had
to stop the car to change so someone
else would sit in the front seat that's
how it went
we had fun and the pictures in
themselves were interesting but I think
what for us was more interesting is they
were telling their own story
and they were telling very powerful
story stories that were not being told
up till that point and that we might not
have the time to show that but that
became important but I also began to
look at other things and this was a
series where I worked on the river
Brahmaputra and I showed this simply
because this is also the time when I'm
trying to make the international
connections the river and how it links
this is a river that goes from China to
India to Bangladesh and how different
countries control rivers and how the
relationship people with rivers changes
and that was the first time I went to
Tibet and then what Fiona's green who
played a very important role in free me
when I was arrested was very involved
with the Free Tibet movement so if she
wanted us to show shoes you've now now
this is the step in your career where
you're an international troublemaker but
getting it but I'm a national
troublemaker too and so we have this
show I don't yeah I'm not gonna deny
that role of course this is Professor
muzaffer Amit who was the chairperson of
transparency international who we
invited to open our show but a show on
Tibet Chinese government leans on our
government who leans on me closes aren't
done our show so we have the opening in
the street and the government provides a
nice background they were there to
protect you well absolutely you see more
protection later on they're aficionados
of art of course yes so but then I also
look to see how else I can make work
because you know if I'm working very
directly then shows get stopped more
easily so at that time there's something
that's happening called crossfire which
was euphemism for extrajudicial killings
and I decided to do shown that this is
something that was bothering people very
much but you know the Rapid Action
Battalion who did the killing weren't
going to take me along yeah by the way
we're about to do a cross but I come
along take some pictures yeah so I had
to find another way and I didn't want
the clothes show to get closed down so
what we did was a lot of research I mean
created images which
we felt were the last images that the
dying person might have seen but we need
something else which was very
significant when I showed the earlier
picture of the wedding it was turned
down everywhere but it was reviewed by a
magazine which belonged to the wife of
the minister and I was very surprised
you know this show being reviewed in the
wife's magazine but they gave a
beautiful review of the artistry of my
word the strength of the composition the
black-and-whites and all that sort of
thing completely ignoring the politics
of course
so I decided okay my work will have the
politics embedded within it so they
cannot separate it so this next work
that I did all the pictures were taken
at the time of the killing mm-hmm when I
spoke to the survivor and well to the
family members they talked of house
torches were shown on their face so
every picture was lit by torchlight
and the data was in a Google Earth Map
and you had to dig for it so you would
then come and see how in this pristine
paddy field there was a body and the
paddy field was undisturbed and the body
had several bullet holes but the shirt
he was wearing only had one so slowly
the story begins to unravel so you
literally went to the killing field and
revealed it but I'm also trying to find
other ways in which but the politics and
the art are intertwined isn't but it's
interesting your Trojan horsing in
completely because you have to within
the constraints of the society you live
and we're showing a photo well well I'm
now allowed to show something but also I
actually found this to be more powerful
and this was perhaps the most effective
exhibit we've had and in private
conversation Rapid Action Battalion has
actually said that this exhibit was the
most difficult period in their career
that they had to deal with yeah if you
don't mind if you can impact the why do
you think this image this image had that
effect what's the power of this I think
the questions are great because they
the show and there were policemen
outside so I interviewed the police and
I'm asking him the same question you
know he's a paddy field it's a problem
he says yeah it's a paddy field they do
look at the word crossfire and you
realized what must have happened in the
paddy field do you make the connection
that's why people worry that's why yeah
and I said does everyone know what
crossfire is my three-year-old daughter
knows what crossfire is I'm filming him
of course while he's doing that and then
later Susan hi we were talking about
this at Tate Modern and I showed that
film so this policeman gives a wonderful
conceptual analysis of my work which I
then include in my work itself so that's
the way we work but I also started
looking at other issues at the
indigenous community indigenous by the
way is something let me show you this
this is the technique that I developed
specifically for this work it's on straw
mat which is where what the buries is to
sleep on and it's been burnt by a laser
beam and it's it's process I developed
for this for this work because a lot of
my work at this point is about
disappearances about the missing
photography is very good at rendering
the visible it's not as good or it
doesn't lend itself as naturally to what
is missing so a lot of my work since
then has been about what is invisible
and I was telling these stories these
are the settlements of the Baha'is
who've occupied this space but it's a
woman called Kalpana Chacma who was
disappeared by the military and I I'm
doing this story 17 years afterwards and
in this dark place when you go into the
galleries the first expression and then
a very powerful poem written in the
Bihari language by the way the word
indigenous is illegal in fact
you can get jailed for using the words
our government bans if we don't have
indigenous peoples so these are people
we need chanting back to st. words
responding this is interesting they
closed down the Tibet showed they closed
down the cross fire show we knew when
this is happening that the military was
surrounding the gallery but they didn't
close it we gained some space but we've
continued to the work and we've done it
in ways in which I think makes it more
difficult for them to stop but I'll move
on
this is a picture I took in 1996 Steven
mais might be somewhere in the back and
the audience but yeah he was then bit
Network Agency and they were doing a
story on HIV and AIDS and I recognized
that it was important showed in my
country because at that time the images
of HIV and AIDS were about skeletons
Doom's dand everything else so we wanted
to deal with the stigma so I do this
story and the woman sitting there
laughing is hadera these she's a sex
worker and the grounds of the house of
parliament that's a beat we became very
good friends we've stayed friends ever
since and that's also one of the joys of
you know how you live in work less than
three miles for where I was born
this is my community these are people I
know and Hadera you know she had a very
difficult life she was gang raped as a
child she she know really very very
difficult like and then I discovered
that she'd taken all her savings to set
up an orphanage great stories we're
gonna love that little pod that
and when I asked her you know I found
out she doesn't take a salary so how
does go she says well you know we helped
and other people that helped you know I
have a roof over my head but my kids eat
I eat I have 30 kids who called me mum
what more than a can I want yeah
and of course you know the floor is the
slate and she's very strict they have to
pray they have to do their studies the
handwriting is actually yeah so anyway
that's why I mean it's so important
right because like regardless of society
its sex worker stigma yeah and then aids
especially in South Asia you don't talk
about it and if whoever gets it of
course as a sinner and then you show
this photo that this person who's a sex
worker dealing with this is actually
using their life to empower others it's
it's so radical and disruptive she's
such a beautiful woman as well what we
also did with the positive life's work
was that was the first time we showed
gay people they don't exist right well
we have a health minister who said we
can't have AIDS cuz we are a Muslim
country anyway so along with that we're
doing other things in it you know I'm
showing my work and I had my first show
at the Goethe Institute I invited all my
friends my clients but also the janitor
and the cleaner and everyone else I used
to know no one went none of them none of
the subaltern went to the show the
people yeah exactly so why didn't you go
and they they asked me a very pertinent
question would they have let us in hmmm
there is no rule that prevents them from
going in but I suspect that another
doorman of the same social class would
have stopped them from going in thinking
that was his job to do so I thought okay
if they can't come to my show the show
must go to them so in chobe mela we've
we've got things like this we've done
shows on boats we've done shows on
camera public exhibit exactly if if the
people won't go to the gallery the
gallery will go to the people and I just
wish we could just stay on this for a
second because we need this in America
big right who can afford some of these
tickets and it's not that we don't have
an appetite for it we do the the
proletariat and the commoner would love
to see beautiful art if only there were
some times allowed in or could pay the
price for the mission just saying
continue what we also did was we looked
to see how stories could be told and I
don't I'm not showing the picture here
but I'll tell you a little story again
during the floods I have a camera and if
you have a camera you're a journalist
you know that's what the assumption is
these kids want me to take pictures so
it's nice light I Caitlin there's a
large open window Rembrandt like soft
light coming in and stand the kids by
there they're standing up at attention
posing away I take the picture I
realized that there's a kid in the
middle is blind boy why is it so
important for him to be photographed and
I've thought about it a lot I mean
essentially in mainstream media in media
generally the people who matter are the
stakeholders and that happens to be the
Punto pace by the newspaper or whatever
the shareholder and advertises no one
else matters and certainly the rural
poor in a country like Bangladesh does
not matter so that story never gets told
so what we started doing was to give the
iPod Touch this is 2011 we worked with
World Press Photo we set up a
partnership and we started training
journalists in the village to tell
stories multimedia stories from the
village which went directly to
mainstream media actually didn't go to
mainstream media at least not in
Bangladesh they weren't prepared to pay
for it there had to be an economic model
it didn't work but Deutsche Welle does
publish it and we put it online and
there are about 1,500 stories from rural
Bangladesh and were they for once are
the protagonists of the narrative it's
their story and I think just you know a
quick aside of what that blot the story
did you just said it's so powerful about
the blind kid who knew like even though
he can't see he he wants to be in the
frame well and he wants to be
represented also well there is a bigger
point you know for me why was it him
important I think that rural poor child
will only exist at a statistic when it
comes to the media when it's large
numbers or things like that you and I
will be individuals they will not but if
a photograph is taken that's the time
when that person exists as an individual
and my idea that through a photograph I
could transform a statistic into a
person a human powerful narrative but of
course we used our work for other ways
there as well I mean we were very much
about social justice about human rights
and when one of the many attacks on cars
that took place we held a show to raise
money to send send to the Palestinians
so we were doing all those sort of
things there was the agency we also set
up the school which became a very
important school at a later stage and
this picture is of professor Yunus at
the what ceremony and you'll notice the
girl on the right that's Robbie who use
so much earlier looking at the contact
sheet many years ago yeah and the school
did very well
for me what was very important is you
know when I started the school I was the
only local teacher and I would arm twist
my friends very generous to come and
sleep on my floor and teach and they did
Robert is there and many other people
have been teachers there but what for me
is very important today is out of our 26
teachers 24 are former students it's
organic they are the ones who set up the
school they take the art I play all the
time it's just one of the pipelines we
should employ everywhere yes you just
student to teacher well exactly I'm very
fine teachers students and teachers as
well this is by Tesla marks are you many
people know this image quite well-known
and this is by Assad for some unknown
magazine you know but they're getting
up-and-coming magazine yes yes it'll get
the independent watch out for it buy
shares it has a future and when this was
done by your former student yep
and Tesla is now a teacher so both of
these pictures are magazine that's so
powerful a former student
girl in Bangladesh who known who would
invest in you gave her a camera you gave
her a little bit of training you just
invested a little bit just a little bit
of your time and caring to her and you
fast forward to three decades and she
has a photo on the cover of one of the
most prestigious magazines were
photographers from around the world
would die for a cover photo
that's that's thanks to you thanks to us
a lot of people go but I should also
mention the picture of a professor Mazar
with the police of the back that was
taken by andrew barrage again a former
student who was with Reuters afterwards
but anyway so let's move on so this is
the backdrop which is an amazing action
shot my friend this is your last book
profile well there you are there's my
tea Dean who took this picture and yeah
so these are what's been happening and
you're in the thick of things by now I'm
I'm actually being able to make a living
as a photojournalist before I wasn't so
but while this is happening there are
other things that are going on and this
is this is powerful this is these are
the stretch marks on the suit of a
garment factory as people are trying to
flee the fire
yeah this is the story in fashion what
what was the response to this photo in
Bangladesh in Bangladesh it didn't get
used very much because mainstream media
it's too abstract and things like that
it got used in my own story and there it
had a very powerful response but it
didn't get used by mainstream media but
we had other ways of dealing with it so
part of this story was off the carcass
of the same time and I took this picture
I took a picture of panorama of the
carcass of the factory the what happens
in garment factories I mean the fashion
industry uses garments so we decided
we'd use their space to show the work so
this is a billboard we set up outside
the building which is the owner owners
association of the garment factories and
what we did was we actually smuggled in
audio tracks of the wailing of the
people who played it in the middle of
the building people came out hearing
this sound we had
performance outside and there's this
they don't know what the heck's going on
here you know they've just run away from
this wailing to come up to this and I do
need to tell you know you might have had
the impression what I'm saying all this
that our government isn't receptive to
the arts you know they gave us a
backdrop earlier on when we had this
show they received us you know yeah
they respond to things like they love
art yes exactly
simply showing that and then I go on to
other things this is a poem I wrote the
Sunderbans we is the world's largest
mangrove forest even esker Heritage Site
at the moment there is a coal powered
power plant being built there in
collaboration with India because we had
beholden to India so you know while we
we owe a lot to India for our
independence the fact that you know we
are now pretty much owned by them is an
issue but this this story is problematic
for a different reason there has been a
young boy called Abra Fahad who was
murdered because he critiqued India on
social media you know that's how
difficult it gets I'll just skim over
some of these this is really powerful I
mean I hope what how let's do it I think
it's a sin to bore an audience how are
you guys doing are you guys with us all
right and and show you though I realize
we're the enemies keeping you from lunch
but you guys are with us right we're
good all right good look we'll fine
this one is beautiful because where do
you guys think this photo was taken
that's that's a question for you guys
anyone
we're like what structure what building
guard okay tell them the answer
it's the by Kirov mosque it's a mosque
it's the interior of a mosque and in
fact that was also part of the idea no I
there are conservative groups who think
photography is haram forbidden forbidden
in many homes when you pray you turn the
photograph around particularly if you
have figures so I thought okay
if I'm going to intervene the space
itself will be my intervention so I
decided I would do a show in a mosque no
way you know so I thought this is
beautiful mosque elder bita roof which
is designed by a woman marina Tabassum
the land has been donated by her
grandmother so there's this woman's
involvement as well and I thought okay I
spoke to Marina and we we look to see
how we might do it so the original
mosque of the Prophet in Medina had a
very different purpose to being merely a
place of Prayer it was a cultural space
it was a community center it was where
education was getting it was a health
complex he received foreign dignitaries
women could stay there
there was a artists group from Abyssinia
who came and said we need a place to
perform and he said use my mosque so it
was also an exhibition space so I told
these people you know I want to take
your mosque bit to where the PAS the
Prophet had intended it to be now that's
a pretty powerful argument it's very
yeah so not too easy to turn down and I
said well one condition only everyone
must be able to go to the church mmm so
we had the show inside the mosque and
people who'd never entered a mosque
before came to this place now we did
have a slight problem before that
because there was a local mafioso not
very happy with this and we had to take
the show outside we did it in the
grounds and then the women the kids came
said why is it not in our mosque so they
took it inside the mosque and I am
nothing but this is a show we're hoping
to tour in other places as well because
Islamophobia is something also I'm very
concerned about it's very transformative
not just for Muslims but also for those
who are otherwise Muslims especially in
the United States right now please
continue so the raw anger situation so
I'm photographing that but what I need
to tell you is that I've been
photographing there owing us from the
early 90s
it's a story now it's a story that's
been there from the 70s yeah so I I was
in the boat with bid these group of
people coming back and the baby with a
green in the green you'll see the
picture later on I could see the mother
was tired so I took the kid and she was
quite happy relieved not to have to
carry the kid and kid was I like kids so
we get along so the kid was with me and
you'll see that picture later on but a
more interesting thing happens more
recent thing happens this is August 29th
of July 2018 there's a road accident and
two students get killed and students
come out in protests and while I'm
photographing this I realize that the
government have released their mafioso
with machetes attacking these unarmed
students and I'm reporting live on this
I give an interview to al-jazeera as a
result of that interview
this happens yeah so and yeah I spent
some time in the entertainment of the
government where I mean if you and you
have a very nice if you were about that
which which is very lovely I think it
keeps you sane but they tortured you
initially I was tortured and then they
offered a deal you know everything's
forgotten all controls delete we take
you back home nothing on the record you
stay quiet
and that was the condition no I could
say quiet I refused I got taken to court
this is a picture of me being taken to
court I spoke out in court
then I could put in remand I spent six
days in remand I go to jail I spent time
in jail but while I was there so many
people across the globe and I see many
people here but in Bangladesh where it's
so much more risky to do that people
took incredible risks to campaign for my
release it was really unbelievable and
for me being in prison it meant a lot
not only to me but also to my fellow
prisoners right because they recognized
that this was a people struggle against
a repressive regime so I'll just show
this picture this is
also taken by someone invented and
that's the same kid taken during the
wringer period so this was part of the
campaign going on and these were people
some unknown people who you know stood
up for me Desmond Desmond Tutu heard
about him up and comer but I say that in
jest but people came I was an intern it
was a multicultural Alliance that came
out to help you and many of your peers
here who were just outraged by the fact
that you who have done so much for art
for your community for education simply
for trying to tell the truth were
arrested and tortured and you were the
Time magazine one of the Time Magazine's
2018 people of the year rightfully so
and so it's the least that the rest of
us could do and that's the power of an
artist and that's the power of a
storyteller that the story eventually
escapes it can't be contained and and so
many people here love you and invest in
you that's also why they came out they
know people you know there there are
many people here I don't know so if some
of you can put me in touch out there I
still would like to thank them at some
point but that's another story
media so what the government has done
over this period of time is they've
they're pretty much demolished all the
institutions the judiciary the police
the education system all of that's gone
so this is the Press Club in Bangladesh
and those are pictures of the Prime
Minister dangling from the Press Club
where is that drink the new building
we're trying to build is Asajj and I
should bring it home I mean this dissent
is not appreciated wherever you go so
it's not so but so we also have our own
version of access journalism absolutely
absolutely but I was then going to do
while I'm in jail this is my sister my
partner they come up and they you can't
talk there's so much noise in there it's
very difficult to converse so they have
a little sign saying do you want to do a
show at Rueben well why not
so anyway and that decision was made
while I was in jail
later on we
able to work on it but even in jail
you're a troublemaker so stay faithful
to lawyer you consistent thank you so
but one of the things we did was of
course I been photographing the
invisible but now I don't have a camera
hmm and that makes photography a little
bit more difficult so what I did was I
started working with my niece Sophia
who's an architect and an artist and we
thought rather than worked with Google
Earth maps and things like that
we brought a memory the memory is a
perfectly valid source so I spoke to her
and she started making 3d models based
on my period in jail and this one is of
me feeding the sparrows from my jail
cell so this is in the Rubin show right
now this little model but one of the
things that's happening now is because
of the situation I'm in I can no longer
move around the way I did so I gotta
find other ways of producing work I no
longer have the mobility I can't go
around on a bicycle this is too
dangerous I have to I don't use a mobile
phone I have to constantly let people
know where I am so my normal way of
working just is no longer valid so I've
developed other ways of working and this
is a story I'm now doing on survivors of
torture but it's using a small mobile
studio which I can take because it's not
safe for them or for me and we can find
a small clandestine place where we can
work selling the studio and I do these
portraits and I talk to them about the
moment when they were in in that
situation and it's it's painful perhaps
but it is a space we try to go to so
this is work I'm doing now this is the
building where Drake and partial are
going to be so my challenge now is
succession I want to hand over to this
next generation and we also have to live
several more decades so just but this
table table the retirement okay okay but
anyway so this is the new
Rick bachelor building great which we
will move into in March hopefully and I
will end with an image which for me was
very important I mean I was looking at
the jail pictures and other things not
that I'm recommending jail but I
actually had a very productive I firstly
I prison was very fruitful for you for
artistic career but also I used that
time to its maximum
you know I interviewed people every day
in it it's not so difficult you know
people have time no you don't need to
make appointments you know you know
where they live yeah
so I could go and do do appointments
which I did I did all these interviews
of whatever the prisoners took such good
care of me right and there was one
instance where I was put in a special
place where ordinary prisoners weren't
allowed to go they sneaked into my room
took away my mosquito net mmm
repaired it washed it put it back in
because they didn't want me to get
bitten by mosquitoes and all sorts at
every level the things they did but for
me the most important one I showed you
the picture of the river earlier that
was deliberate because this is a mural
that my fellow prisoners have painted
for me inside prison it's there now so
amazing yeah if
it's you know it's it's it's it's a
testament to your not just your
creativity in your artistry but your
spirit its the generosity of your spirit
which has touched the prisoners which
has touched students which has disrupted
and angered the right people and we've
run out of time but entertain me for two
minutes if you can because you know sure
he look kind of glanced over his life
right now he goes oh like you know I
just ride in my after right I can't ride
my bike anymore it's okay I'd get stuff
done but we were talking yesterday at
Pete's coffee this is very elite
establishment and I was asking him you
know tell me about the impact and the
cost and he was telling me he says you
know I have to tell people where I'm at
all the time he used to ride his bike
freely he works like literally three
miles from where he was born he cannot
ride his bike anywhere your friends are
being squeezed to isolate and pressure
you money is being tightened they are
doing all of this to restrict your art
to hurt your financial sustainability I
mean he has paid a price and I just want
people to kind of realize that that he's
still paying the price right now things
are very difficult for him and daca and
yet he's still doing this and so how can
we help you take it to the next level
firstly I think you need to challenge
your own government because yeah
and I'm not merely talking about the
political situation you know the reason
these things happen is because it's made
to happen so you know there are people
there are countries that talk about
human rights and democracy yet we've had
a government that's still an election
we've had what's happened to me what's
happened to me is minor compared to what
happens to many others yet as far as
international community is concerned is
business as usual right because they
would much rather work with a plan
dictator than with some messy democracy
and as long as my government is prepared
to deal with the raw anger issue and
deal with the war on terror and you know
create deal with your agenda a few human
rights abuses it's okay let me don't
really mind that and I think those tough
questions need to be asked here that's
one the other is I am interested in the
people I'm one person there are so many
people back there who are working
incredibly hard and I think we need to
find ways in which we strengthen these
institutions so that they can be robust
than they could withstand because one of
the things I'm often asked is okay this
government is the other government is
much better either why why should we
choose the other one it's the wrong
question because given impunity Gabriel
would be corrupt and I think we have a
system where if people can get away with
anything and while that is the case
while there is no accountability while
there's no transparency you will always
have repression and corruption and I
think what has to change is not the
people necessarily but the system and
that we need to work together right well
since he's not gonna do it he can also
help him by buying his book
which has the story and the photos and
also talked to some Oh who's right here
because he has a brilliant idea to take
that photographic exhibit that he showed
you about how he disrupted the mosque
and tore it with other faith communities
in New York and to put a final button on
it and to take us to lunch you were the
you had an accidental birth you were an
accidental
photographer and what people might not
know is you were accidentally named
because your name at birth was not
Shaheed oh and on that story okay well
my father's professor Massoud quite a
famous man I didn't know this we have a
library back home and I'm digging
through that and I come up with monsoons
media which is named after my dad but
you know he forgot to mention that
anyway so a my mom's quite well-known to
my brother and I we decided we didn't
really want to be known as the children
of famous parents we wanted an identity
for ourselves so we went to our parents
that said we want to change our names
why and we gave them this argument they
thought it was a reasonable argument so
I was given the name Shahid Alam which
actually the way it's built at that time
was a witness of the world at some point
it became martyr of the world so I'm not
sure quite where I stand right now
witness let's stick with the illness and
actually there is a referenced in in
Egyptian mythology about linkages
between witness in martyrs so but that's
another story
give it up there - Shaheed or alum
witness of the world thank you thank you
very much to be on topic thank you
you're the one
once you take a picture nice take a
picture this way thank you don't go away
I'll take a picture of you well it won't
be a selfie can you guys just yep kinda
no I'm gonna make this pun
Wow I've been suit thank you buddy take
them well thank you everyone
a reminder cameras can be cleaned your
badge is good for admission to the
museum across the hall there's two great
shows in there and 20% off in the gift
shop and by a taste videos upstairs take
your belongings with you please we'll
start back up at 2:00 p.m. in this room